nos piden arrastrar el punto a 12.5 en
la recta numérica vamos a ver aquí
tenemos 12 y 12.5 está entre el 12 y el
13 luego nos preguntan cuál es el
resultado de redondear 12.5 a la decena
más cercana bueno lo interesante de esto
es que la recta numérica pueden ver que
las escenas tienen esta línea azul aquí
tenemos 10 y luego 20 y estamos entre el
10 y el 20 de cual estamos más cerca
cuál es literalmente la decena más
cercana bueno pueden ver que estamos más
cerca de 10 que de 20 así que el
resultado es 10 y esto nos ayuda a
desarrollar nuestra intuición de lo que
significa redondear a la decena más
cercana
probablemente conozcas una regla que
dice que vayas a una posición menor que
la posición de las decenas y si es menor
que cinco entonces redondea hacia abajo
hacia 10 y si es igual a 5 o mayor
entonces redondea 20 pero aquí podemos
ver que estamos más cerca de 10 hagamos
otro ejemplo
aquí nos piden que arrastremos el punto
a 0.136 este es 0.13 este es 0.14 aquí
tenemos 13 centésimas y aquí 14
centésimas vamos a ver aquí tenemos 1 2
3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 podríamos pensar en
éstas como milésimas tenemos 10
milésimas entre estas dos centésimas así
que tenemos 13 centésimas y luego otras
6 milésimas entonces vamos a ver
avanzamos
1 2 3 4 5 6 justo aquí y luego nos dicen
cuál es el resultado de redondear 136
milésimas o 0.136 a la centésima más
cercana bueno tenemos las centésimas en
azul y cuál es la más cercana estamos
más cerca de 14 centésimas 0.14 y esto
es consistente con lo que hemos visto en
otros casos donde buscas la posición de
las miles
y 105 mayor redondeadas hacia arriba en
este caso redondeamos a 14 centésimas
hagamos otro ejemplo digamos que nos
preguntan cuál de los puntos se
encuentra en 44.192 obre la recta
numérica vamos a ver este tiene que
estar entre 44 y 45 así que está justo
aquí debe ser el punto ce y luego nos
preguntan cuál es el resultado de
redondear 44 puntos 197 al entero más
cercano bueno hay un par de maneras de
pensar en esto podríamos simplemente
mirar el lugar de las escenas y decir
bueno es menor que 5 así que redondeamos
hacia abajo hacia 44 otra manera más
intuitiva de pensar en esto es mirar el
punto ce que es el punto que nos
interesa aquí está 44.192 el entero más
cercano está más cerca de 44 o está más
cerca de 45 claramente está más cerca de
44 esta es otra razón por la que 44 es
la
hagamos otro ejemplo digamos que
queremos saber cuál es el resultado de
redondear a la milésima más cercana y
cuál es el resultado de redondear a la
centésima más cercana vamos a
orientarnos aquí está el punto a 0.07
son siete centésimas acá tenemos ocho
centésimas podemos ver esto como 70
milésimas 71 milésimas 72 milésimas 73
milésimas 74 milésimas y así
sucesivamente el punto a está entre 78
milésimas y 79 milésimas por lo tanto si
tenemos que redondear a la milésima más
cercana definitivamente se ve más cerca
de 78 milésimas que de 79 milésimas
yo diría entonces que el resultado es
cero punto 0 78 ó 78 milésimas
esa es la milésima más cercana cuál es
el resultado de redondear a la centésima
más cercana
bueno cuáles son las centésimas entre
las que se encuentra el punto ar
está entre 7 centésimas y 8 centésimas y
cuál es la centésima más cercana bueno
está más cerca de 8 centésimas 0.08 una
vez más el punto importante de este
vídeo es entender que cuando la gente
dice redondea al entero más cercano oa
la decena más cercana oa la milésima más
cercana oa la centésima más cercana
podemos pensar en una recta numérica y
simplemente preguntarnos cuál es la
centésima más cercana o que es centésima
está más cerca cuál millesimé está más
cerca en la recta numérica terminamos